it feels like this game is the game is
ending because the H1 just wins now
we'll see a handshake any second hmm
uh yeah simply a good game by Wesley
we've got to say but Vincent there was a
critical moment he let things go and in
this difficult end game he yeah this
might be one idea I think it was that's
that's the final
um
kind of slip final mistake oh no it was
earlier yeah it was here I wonder how
much time he had at this point
uh because
it is more 33 and if you went very very
low on time at this point it may be
justifiable but it's it is such a yeah
and there there you have it it looks
like there
uh signing the score sheets
uh so yeah Vincent also uh loses a
couple in a row he lost this very very
long game to live on yesterday
and lose another one uh today
but when the tournament isn't really
going your way particularly duplex in